If you've ever played the Super Nintendo classic
Super Mario World, you've seen it.
As Yoshi and Mario gallivant through each
level, Yoshi pulls a Miley Cyrus circa 2015
to grab certain items with his tongue, at
Mario's command.
While some players argued that their favorite
mustachioed plumber was simply pointing at
what he wanted Yoshi to slurp up, others had
a more sinister suggestion: Mario was actually
punching Yoshi in the head.
Believe it or not, we've since discovered
that Team Head Punch was absolutely right.
In an interview on Nintendo's official site
in September 2017, Super Mario World developers
Takashi Tezuka and Shigefumi Hino discussed
how the character of Yoshi evolved, including
his much buzzed-about tongue animation.
Hino said, "Lots of people think that while
Mario is pointing his finger forward, he's
saying 'Go,' and Yoshi's tongue comes out.
However, the setup that I drew was that when
Mario punches Yoshi in the head, the character's
tongue shoots out in surprise."
But the developers didn't want gamers to think
Mario was mean, so the official explanation
became that Mario was merely gesturing at
what he wanted his dino pal to retrieve.
Official game art was drawn up to reflect
this as well, but there was no change to the
actual animation in the game, which was low-res
enough to obscure the Yoshi-abuse.
Hino also said there used to be a "bop" sound
to accompany the punch, but, "it seemed like
people would say 'Poor Yoshi,'" so they changed
it to this sound …
… which Hino says is supposed to represent
Mario saying "Go!"
So now you know — the in-game animation
was, indeed, intended to depict Mario punching
his trusty dino-steed into submission, but
Nintendo covered up the mistreatment with
a sweeter sound effect and some very effective
propaganda.
"That'll teach you to mess with my new little
buddy Yoshi!"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!